what is this five-year pursuit taught
you about dreams making them happen
setbacks coming back again what does it
taught you about a journey of seeing
something evolve and and come to life
sure yeah sure all of my major projects
I know going in will take years so for
instance when I wrote The Twilight Zone
companion which is my first book that
took five years from the month I started
a month book came out the book has been
in print for over 30 years now and so
and so and when I was writing it someone
said to me what are you gonna be done
and I said I'll be done when it's right
and because I took the time to make it
right it stood the test of time it
lasted the book I just wrote with
guillermo del toro it took me four years
and during during all these periods I'm
working on multiple projects I like to
multitask I like to do many things at
once my new Space Command would be a
massive project the first two hours have
the first two our story has 1900 visual
effects shots
that's more than star wars and a big
episode of Battlestar Galactica would
have 200 is do hunt 200 visual effects
shots this has 1900 in the first two
hours so I knew there would be
incredibly ambitious and but the steps
in space command were raised the money
to get thing going continue to raise
money by selling shares shoot the first
two hours and then lock down in a
powerful agency that then gives me the
credibility to go and pitch the networks
and sell the show and so all of those
things are very time-consuming and it
it's like a military campaign so I knew
it would take years and and but we're
further along or closer to being towards
finish line than to at the beginning
because we've shot you know two hours of
shot the entire first story we shot 30
minutes for the second story and now I'm
pitching the series and whoever buys
that will have to pick up the first
season and that's 12 episodes and we're
getting a very good response we're you
know but it comes from putting in the
work because now we could say this is
what this is this is what it looks like
here it is here's the thing itself and
that's a great great experience there's
a truism about almost any television
show or film where everybody then said
if I'd never been as hard
never would have started it and and and
but once you're in you can't turn around
then they jump into another project you
know so they had no memory but it just
happened so I think you know some of it
is it is kind of a wild horse but when
you're on you're not to either let go
but there are arts with in terms of our
disappointments and certain things you
can't foresee for instance we brought a
board there was a visual effects genius
that I'd worked with many times in my
career he won an Emmy for Star Trek
Voyager he designs Babylon 5 and we
invented television how visual effects
were done in television and he did the
Star Trek episode that I did with Elaine
and I did with George Takei we did a few
years ago two got nominated for the Hugo
and the nebula Awards so I brought him
aboard Space Command and he fell ill and
and sadly died his name was Ron Thornton
and he was a genius but sadly he didn't
get to see yes cue through to the finish
line and that's just what life does
sometimes you know you never know he he
was only he was like 59 it's very sad
and so but again you just tried for
anyone who wants to produce I'm more
producer than Mark Martin you know
billions better and wiser than me and
everyone and then I'm a detail person
but I always say you know it's a thing
is that some people feel things are
going awry that they're not producing
well which is that's just what happens
that's being a producer so I try
servicing producing anything in sec it's
a spinning ball by spinning very quickly
and things are flying off into space and
your job as a producer is to tack back
things as quickly as you can and we
always make the assumption that the
thing you're going to tack back on will
be better than the thing that swirled
off into space and you're not doing
anything wrong it's just the nature of
production and if you have that headset
and you're not like beating yourself up
you're just moving as fast as you can
and keeping your eye on the ball you'll
be much happier producer right and also
again you know Elaine it's funny because
some because of Lena live them together
for 40 years and married for 39 animals
together so much people some were very
similar but in reality were very very
different Elaine for one is same but but
paternity she's calmer than I am I'm a
warrior I'm very my head is very very
busy I beat myself up a lot but I'm the
one with the big vision I'm the one who
well
I'll take on something that's crazily
big for instance when I wrote The
Twilight Zone companion it was - I
started that book two years after Rod
Serling died and I had graduated from
UCLA with a degree in painting sculpture
and graphic arts I told one short story
I had never sold an article I've never
taken a journalism class and I decided I
was going to write a book about the
twilight zone
now I had already heard the Carol
Serling Rods Widow had turned down major
journalists so if I had asked a hundred
people what my chance of getting Rod
Serling's Widow to let me do a book
about the twilight zone was 100 people
would have said you have no chance I was
22 years old but it's not a majority
opinion your fate is not majority
opinion you out vote the world if you
decide you're going to do something and
so then it just became strategic it's
like how do I go about doing this so
what I did was I met one writer from the
Twilight Zone
one writer from Twilight Zone George
Clayton Johnson I met him when I was 16
years old as a science fiction
convention and we became friends so I
interviewed him about the Twilight Zone
he connected me up with two other people
who worked on the show and I interviewed
them and over a three-month period I
interviewed 30 people and work on the
show then I went to Carol Serling and by
then I know a lot about the show and I
felt very confident that I could do this
book and so I went to her house it was
rods house it was exactly as rod had
left it his Emmys were there six Emmys
there was one room just for the trophies
and so six Emmys three Hugo's the
Peabody Award all that stuff his dog was
still there the senile Irish Setter
it all in his office was intact exactly
as he left it and I remember standing in
this huge living room with Carol
Sterling sitting on the couch and for
some reason I was standing and I told
her what I had in mind and I could
envision that future of my completing
the book successfully as clearly as I
see you and I spoke very convincingly
and I knew what I was talking about
because I'd done my research and as she
and she talked to some of the people I
did interviews and the people she knew
and trusted and they clearly gave me a
good bill of self a good rapport because
she came back and she said okay you've
got full access to everything and so I
spent several years crawling through
rods attic and in his garage there were
the 16 millimeter film film prints in
these big film cans of the tweye
episodes I would take on the state a
stack like this and put them on the
projector they had the original
commercials becoming attracting spots
now some of these prints have never even
been through a projector and and I wrote
the book and so so that but it's a
crazily ambitious project as well as his
Space Command and I actually enjoy big
challenges Thank You hydros enough in
time as a test yeah well you know that
was another crazy thing to do it was um
that was sort of the test run as Elaine
said it was basically uh I was at a
science-fiction convention and this is
just when the Star Trek and when
Enterprise was kind of fading it was
dying down fans haven't embraced it and
and this is before JJ Abrams said he was
going to do the Star Trek movie and so
this I was on a panel for Star Trek's I
vote for Star Trek The Next Generation
in Deep Space nine and someone from the
audience said well what's the future of
Star Trek and Walter Keane included
Chekov gave this answer and it was a
crazy answer so crazy that afterwards I
said tell me all about this I was
talking for about an hour and he told me
that there were group of fans in upstate
New York who had built a full-sized copy
of all the original Star Trek sets from
the blueprints they were shooting their
own Star Trek episode then putting them
on line and they were getting a larger
audience than Enterprise was getting on
UPN and he was about to fly to New York
and be in an episode starring himself as
Chekov and written by DC Fontana Dorothy
Fontana would written story edited the
original Star Trek series so that night
I went online and they had an episode of
they had done which is a sequel to an
episode the original Star Trek had done
called the doomsday machine and it had
William Windom who dim in that the guest
star in that episode that it was it was
great fun and so I offended mine years
ago and come up with a great Sulu
episode they were gonna bring Star Trek
back in the 70s paramount was and then
Star Wars came out and after year of
development they made the movie instead
of the series they've been developing
and so my friend had pitched to them a
great Star Trek episodes starring Sulu
and it didn't get made and both he and I
have written for Star Trek The Next
Generation he was an Emmy winner and I
called him I said one write this episode
he said sure we know the two of us and
so I called the boys in upstate New York
and I said hey we wanted the Sulu
episode and I won directed because I'd
always wanted to direct and they said
sure and I said but we have to shoot
they'd been shootin mini DV and they
said yeah well if you can get the
cameras and I said okay and then I went
to George Takei and I sat in his kitchen
his living room actually dining room and
and I gave him I type of three-page
outline of what the story would be and I
said you never got the great Sulu
episode you deserved this is it I need
you to tell me if you'll do it so he sat
there any read the three pages he said
I'm in so we spent six months building
our production team we shot nine days in
upstate New York on the enterprise steps
we built sous-chef P via SVM what's it
called the Sulu ship Excelsior yes it's
the Excelsior so we built to ship the
Excelsior here in LA so we shot two days
here in LA and one day in Florida with
the effects team was a solid year of
post-production 700 visual effects shots
it's called Star Trek world nothing time
you can actually watch it on my website
Mark Zachary comm in its entirety and it
got nominated for the Hugo and nebula
which are the two top awards in science
fiction first time any independent
project had ever been nominated for
those awards we did it without a studio
or a network we did it for under
$100,000 and and it looks as good in any
Network show you'd ever see and and I
showed it I said to George when we're
shooting a year from now you and I will
be at the world science fiction
convention in Japan we'll be showing
this to an audience of several thousand
people and at the end will answer
questions I'll be speaking English he'll
be speaking in Japanese because he's
fluent and and I said a year later we'll
be nominated for Hugo and all that stuff
came true and and when we showed it in
Japan it's 3,000 people in the audience
and we got standing ovations people were
in tears at the end because it was so
moving and and so you know so I had that
vision I was I was speaking a future
that I made happen and but the fact that
I was able to do that without a studio
our network then showed that I could
create something without that
infrastructure and that showed me that I
could do space command and that that
gave me the credibility to pull it off
oh if that all sounds so smooth and
telling you know quite a few bumping
bits as we were doing this the team got
very worried about high-def the initial
team because they were very worried that
that it would show a multitude of flaws
in their sets which it did not I mean
there was a beautiful no but there was a
lot of concern
about hi definitely then use from then
on but there were minute and the acting
of the initial team who had put together
they were fans it needs a little bit of
polishing for some of them some of them
are pros some of them were not and they
were they were good enough to be
enthusiastic about actor camp which we
set up so we had an actor camp but there
were a lot of little person that we were
here we didn't crop we want to have the
strongest acting chops of the event and
they were very open to to learning so
that the one who is playing captain
curtains I was playing Captain Kirk who
was okay he was fine you know but but at
one point he was like really eager he
was working and he got applauded after
one scene that he then and then he was
really you know with the with a learning
curve so but but there was a lot of
tension you know people were being
pressed to come to a really high level
and and that's where I was my job was
being the H HDH which was the hothead D
hotter fired when people were starting
to get a little bit tense members on
option it can and he was just driving
and driving and driving it or so it was
and the final day you should talk about
George Takei on that final day well we
should see was just amazing we shot a
very very long day and the last tape he
did was one take it was perfect and how
many hours with that 25 20 hours a day
and he was up there after a 20-hour day
never complained yeah and instead of
lifting weights and getting in shape he
lost 15 pounds and he wasn't in bad
shape
oh god it did great day and then you
involved then on qf like a 20-hour day
he was standing on that stage while the
tribes on the transport stage with a
single tear tracking down his face
exactly on cue that was appropriate
Mussina wasn't things no no he'd been
working before no thank you he was just
he was just phenomenal so there was a
tremendous pressure so I mean there were
a lot of stories but so it wasn't easy
it's never easy but as we crazily driven
ya have to just be the engine that
doesn't stop and and that's when you
have a calling that's when you I mean if
you're doing it for the wrong reasons if
you're doing it because you want to
prove something to your parents or you
want to you know as I said make a lot of
money or you
want to just kind of you crap work and
have that somehow slide by those are all
the wrong reasons you know there's a
friend of mine his name's Frank Spotnitz
he was executive produced through the
x-files he created and when men in the
high castle and he's got four shows on
the air right now and he said good
enough is never good enough and I
absolutely believed that but with these
fans they were like really driven they
were doing it out of love and even if
they get angry at each other you know
there's never enough time is never
enough resources you always try to
protect your department against other
departments you might do your best job
but but there's still for all the
attentions they were a delight to work
with because they were doing what they
love
you